the argument I make in the book for why
prostitution invariably causes trauma to
women in particular is partly with the
fact it's extraordinarily dangerous and
has very high rates of violence but also
I think the reason it's invariably
experienced as traumatic is because a
very very deep-seated Instinct within
women which has a very obvious and clear
evolutionary background is we really
care a lot about who we have sex with
but make choices very very important
which does make sense if you understand
the fact that men and women have
different making strategies and it's
very much in women's interest to be
picky about who they get pregnant by
because pregnancy is extremely demanding
on the body labor is dangerous you then
have a baby to look after however many
years afterwards which is abandoned on
you burn on your community you don't
want to get pregnant by some Bozo who
either has terrible genes or is it going
to abandon you so that desire to invest
wisely unisexual Partners is very very
deep-seated and what prostitution does
is it violates that choice and I think
that is a big part of the reason why it
has this very deeply felt emotional
response